I have my last screen test in New York
the day before I started rehearsal in
Australia for like mines and so I took
these sleeping pills I had to go
straight off the plane to go and
rehearse with Toni Collette and I had a
cup of coffee
two cups of coffee in order that I could
be present in the rehearsal in the
second day of rehearsal I arrived and
halfway through the day she was like
Eddie it's really nice to meet you
properly because yesterday you were
insane you were literally a crazy person
I didn't come from particularly
theatrical families but as a kid my mom
and dad would take my brothers and I -
basically - lame is sporadically so when
I heard that was coming along I was
quite keen on the idea I was doing a
film at the time a film called hick in
which I'll bring a Texan meth addict
pedophile with a limp and down in North
Carolina and I remember hearing no date
so in my trailer dressed as a Texan meth
addict pedophile always recorded myself
singing a song from it
it's this very odd thing because it was
directed by Tom Hooper who I'd worked
with and lied to once on another when I
was doing my Elizabethan period as I did
another part in another visa thing and
so I'd worked with him before I knew him
quite well and he was a Powell I was
interested in this part but I didn't
want to go to him directly and you just
but also you don't want him to have to
have the humiliation of telling you that
you sing tone-deaf and there's no chance
of you doing it so I should have sent
this audition in dressed as a Texan
method people into the ether and
unfortunately came back yeah and so that
was it was an interesting experience
[Music]
you have this earpiece in your ear and
there's a pianist playing into your ear
but what they record is totally live so
if you're on set it's kind of ridiculous
because all you hear is his boos
people's singing random without any
accompaniment but what's also quite
tricky is they were always going to
replace that
tinkly little piano you can barely hear
in your ear with like a huge Orchestra
at moment but at that moment his
character's singing about the death of
his pals and it felt that the way into
that shouldn't be I'm about to sing a
song it should be more like him just
thinking the the thought process guy
that's pretty intent on Hoover is
amazing but the guy is like he he likes
to create situations that are real so
for example in that film we build
barricades and rather than like my shots
lost building the barricade he basically
had five cameramen dressed up as
peasants and had a shed ton of furniture
and to all of us actors playing students
was just like go build a barricade which
is really fun in here courti real until
a [ __ ] piano is basically falling on
my head you know and there's a fact I've
still got a scar here from this one
moment where we're saying this song do
you hear the people sing and what this
revolution I suppose starts in this
moment and we jump off this hearse when
we I jump on horses and he had like a
new right the horse through there and
you fire this gun and you do all that
and it was all done for real and I this
feels more dangerous I'll be fine I'll
be fine anyway what happens when you
film these since you get such pumped
adrenalin I had to shoot this Flint gun
halfway through it and there's chaos
everywhere horses cook has got to the
other scene those blood like pouring all
over my hand and I basically like the
Flint had sliced into my hand suddenly
they were like medic we need a medic to
Eddie his blood although this which
point Thomas I was like now you come
grind when there's little blood on our
hand but but he kept it real Elizabeth
the Golden Age
you know if you're a British actor
you're gonna have your period drama
moment like the reason sort of British
filmed as well they just got like a
massive history of stories and of kings
and queens and royalty so if in doubt we
just have dig into that no I got to work
with Cate Blanchett on the Golden Age
and I basically had very little to do
except at one point running to Ely
Cathedral and scream [ __ ] really loudly
at Cate Blanchett
but I'll never forget watching her on
that set and shoot this was the sequel
to Elizabeth and she was so formidable
in that film and we're seeing her assess
she was sitting there with just her
earphones in and she was just going T T
round Royal literally working on her
dialect and it was just as a kind of
work ethic thing haven't you won the
Oscar for that you've got this down Kate
you're fine but watching that those
people that you admire you sort of see
them in the films you see them on the
red carpet and you forget that in the
midst of that is a staggering wonderful
hard work and and the greats like like
Kate never stopped you a Good Shepherd
it was the most amazing experience I was
playing Matt Damon and Angelina
journey's son I was basically cast
because I had massive lips but it was
the most intense experience me excited
um one film but I had barely any
experience on camera and he was flown to
New York you know put up an amazing
hotels and you'd go to work every day
and these big blacked-out cars and we
were shooting in Brooklyn and there
would be paparazzi everywhere and then
they would suddenly their camera here
and there'd be Angelina and Matt and
Robert De Niro behind the thing and
there'd be like action and well I
basically just saw War II just like
carved across my face and so when I
watch that film back which it was an
amazing experience but I just see total
total fear scored across my village
well there are a lot of things you can
do I'd like you to think about this very
carefully I have thought about it
carefully that's what I want to do I
want to join the agency dinero has this
wonderful technique he would do this
thing when quite a few of my scenes were
pretty emotional in that film and he
would allow you to play the scene and
then he'd tell you to go back in and to
channel the emotion from the end of the
scene back into the beginning of the
scene and you do it over and over again
and acting as well those things you take
all these processes that you learn over
the years and you sort of create your
own process and that was one of my first
sort of major lessons but I did my
audition met De Niro for first time and
he was quite quiet and he just looked at
me and he said done what so he's party
hair just like I was like and he
basically want me to comb my hair as I
have a cut he's like no go away they've
come back and you can as I okay so I
sent down into Oxford Street in London
went to boots
hello pharmacy got home and came back
like a few hours later my hair really
combed it was in London it was years
before it got made and at the time
Leonardo DiCaprio was playing the role I
was sitting waiting as other actors went
in and someone passed through the
doorframe and I said to the casting
assistant who's in there and they were
like well Bob obviously and Leo know
what you're auditioning with Leonardo
DiCaprio and about two minutes later I
was there doing this intense scene
within our DiCaprio playing his son like
breaking down on him he was like sort of
hugging me I had this timeout moment in
which I was something looking down on
the whole thing going that's Robert De
Niro and they're seeing DiCaprio and I
I feel so as I was quite an intense some
intense audition process I was amazing I
suspect some nuzzling intially aren't
DiCaprio's armpit Jupiter ascending
never watching Cloud Atlas was kate mara
and and I think Rooney Mara in the
cinema and it just being like the most
extraordinary bonkers thing I had ever
seen as was Jupiter ascending it was I
feel like we have this this spread in
England toast which is called Marmite
and like the ad slogan is you like
either like it or you hate it and I've
always thought myself as a bit of a
Marmite actor people seem to like I
don't enjoy what I do or knows what I do
and those people that loathe what I do
Jupiter ascending tends to be their
favorite what was I I want a prize for
it for the worst performance of the year
so yeah I was pretty bad performance
okay in Jupiter ascending my character
had had his like larynx ripped out by
this Wolfman and so I made this slightly
bold choice of which I thought was right
of talking like this for the whole film
which I felt sort of suited the costumes
and the extremity of the world but in
retrospect it may have been too much
I believe Titus is aware of that guards
my spies whisper but cannot substantiate
so you have a print but you don't over
but I love the Wachowski because I'd
never felt so free on set
Lana would just scream like notes from
should like do it like an accountant she
would say but my interpretation of that
was delight shout really loudly which is
always very all because I have a really
quiet like kind quite gentle accountant
rather than a sort of hardcore
imperialist autocrat yeah savage grace
savage grace is a film that not many
people have seen but weirdly was one of
the films I'm most passionate about
again another part that I was I think I
was pretty much cast because I had
freckles I've been very grateful for
massive lips freckles though and some of
our greatest actresses having big lips
and freckles and I remember the last
audition for that with Julie walking in
and she looked like my son that's
amazing
best thing yeah that was that was an
intense experience basically very very
few people have seen this film but the
year when I did theory of everything
and when Julianne Moore won the Oscar we
were both we've had this discussion
backstage both of us like soaps have
blown away that we had just had the most
amazing evening of our lives but maybe
people will go back and we still have
the collar and I think of genuinely of
all the films I've ever made I had the
most joyous experience it was set in
like cadaques London New York Paris all
of it was shot in Barcelona in the
extraordinary heat and made for very
little money
Spanish crew so wine at lunchtime and I
remember it being really wonderful time
Spanish actors as well Elena and I are
near knocks again the Danish girl
while we were doing lemmas a Rob Thomas
said I've got this script and I'd love
you to read it but then I it wasn't
possible because it wasn't possible to
get financed that film had been around
for a long long time
Nicole Kidman had been attached to it
and they're getting it financed was
tricky so it didn't happen and then
fortunately theory of everything came
out and it meant because we're all
commodities act as you're only basically
all real value I had to suddenly shot up
a little bit as a consequence of the
successive theory and so we got to make
that film and that was an extraordinary
thing because the people I met prepping
for that part people from the trans
community the amount I learned sort of
mistakes I made all of it has been a
very formative thing an amazing thing
but it wasn't intense film to to make
you've always sketched me better than I
was but what you drew overcome you make
me beautiful so now you're making me
strong just before our film came out
Caitlyn Jenner have been on the front of
Vanity Fair Verne Cox was in the cover
of Time magazine and it felt perhaps
that it was time for trans people to be
telling their stories and there was a
certain amount of backlash which I've
felt from that which I understood and
sort of agreed with but what was
interesting as I said have committed to
it quite a long time beforehand but yeah
so there's a it's a copy it's a
complicated experience because I learnt
a lot and I met extraordinary people and
I still haven't necessarily reconciled
whether it was then yeah when it was the
right thing to do it was made by working
title who I adore and I have to thank
their our British production house I
have to thank them for basically a
career but they made limits Rob and
there was a point when we're promoting
them is arrived where I got a call from
agent being like they want you to go to
Japan for the DVD release I was working
at times I don't know if I've I've got
time really and my agent was like no no
no but it's working title and there's
something but you should go you know in
order to like you know you keep these
guys happy there's some of the biggest
employers in this culture so anyway I
went to Japan and which was amazing but
and some released the DVD and came back
and made
it's amazing script about Stephen
Hawking that's I wow it's been made by
working title sounds amazing love it can
I have a meeting here like yeah that no
they don't they don't want to meet you
on it alright wait a [ __ ] second my
literature pardon what it's a stay in
with working title like surely I can get
a music I think we just used guilt to
strong-arm a meeting unfortunately six
or seven other actors who I really
admire had fortunately turned down the
part and I met with James Marsh who was
a wonderful documentary maker and he
didn't make me audition like we talked
about it and he sort of gave me this
part and and when you have that
experience you have sort of complete
euphoria followed by utter utter horror
fear of like because I didn't audition
for it
how does he have faith in me because I
have no idea whether I can do this like
at least if you've auditioned they've
seen some sense of it so it's basically
what didn't happen on that film was I
was just so terrified that you just have
to if you're playing a real guy who
would see the film and it is renowned
for not mincing his words and his whole
family would see the film there was
basically no question but to just like
work your balls off which is why try to
oh wow
[Music]
simple elegant evasion
it was extraordinary but I have this
thing I've done of other people have it
when you're so fueled with adrenaline
and you just can't remember anything the
next thing I remember is you get taken
straight into this press conference and
there are all these journalists around
the world but you are literally like
totally caught in the headlights you
don't know basically human bodies can't
contend that that much thrill and
anxiety or mind couldn't there was this
last question from an Australian
journalist that was like so any I hear
that these two actors from Australia we
like your massive inspirations and
influences and their two brilliant
actors from the Australian television
soap called neighbours which I grew up
watching and loved having just been
onstage in front of all these strong
people their adrenaline pumping and
fuelling being asked about neighbours
were so surreal that I sort of think I
went and sort of passed out afterwards
but the greatest thing that came from
that was lovely Jackie who is
extraordinary in place Susan Kennedy she
heard about it and then I was offered a
part in Mayville as like us to cameo
which I yet to take up on I don't know
actually if the invitation stood out
there but laughs fantastic beasts and
where to find them I read the first few
books because my brother had loved them
and was completely enticed by them and
so I kind of love them and ice to go and
watch the films every year because I
felt like escapism and yet it also like
all the characters were kind of touchy
so I was a fan but at the way in which
this this film came about was kind of
most secretive so my dad and my family
all working like proper jobs and my dad
has a briefcase and so I had decided
that I BRE food be my set bag the thing
that I took to set with all my work to
try and feel like I was doing a proper
job and I had this call that David Yates
this director wanted to talk to him
about an unknown project and we kind of
went to this club in solo home and it
was next to a fire and it was like
something out of pot and I arrived at my
briefcase and he started telling me this
story that JK Rowling was writing about
this character and about this creatures
and then about this case and I gently
found missiles shoving this thing back
my case from on the table cuz I didn't
want him to think that somehow I'd come
dressed as the character which quite a
lot of actors do do and I don't think
isn't necessarily the wisest thing
anyway I eventually got Karsten it has
been
it's been like a shedload of fun and
that's it feeds the crimes adrenaline
they invited me back the great news is
on the back of her fantastic beasts book
that new wrote like there's like yeah he
lives happily married in Dorset
you never know a Joey she could take it
anywhere but at least he survives you
know for a while and coming back for
number two is amazing because got to
work with Johnny Depp and Jude Law and
how does it guys I grew up kind of
loving their work so they have amazing
puppeteers who come and they sort of
show you what the creatures do and how
they move and then you kind of look at
the director he's like I'd rather now
those guys leave and you imagine it so I
think it was picking it who's this
little beau chuckle figure who kind of
I've been on the tube in London and I
just imagine talking to him and and I do
that quite a lot with accents as well
like all sort of record them on my phone
and listen to them and then occasionally
now I realize that people taking photos
of me or like cat or recording me while
I'm like chatting to pick it with my
imaginary friend and there's all kinds
of sad and weird and deranged
[Music]